-How are you?
-I'm good.
I just left a city full of
people dressed like that.
-Yeah, everybody in Washington
is very happy.
It's been --
When was the last time
a Washington sports team
won a title?
Was it, like,
early '90s or something?
-I can't even remember.
-It's been a long time.
So, that's the -- I'm glad --
-I don't root for any of 'em.
-You don't watch --
you know, you're a --
-I'm a Philadelphia fan.
-So you probably,
more often than not,
actively work against them,
right?
-I do everything I can
to sabotage them.
[ Laughter ]
-So, I want to talk about
the book.
But first, obviously,
you managed to do this while you
still have your day job.
And yesterday -- Often on
Sunday, you are the first
to catch what would be called --
I guess politely be called spin.
-Spin.
-Larry Kudlow,
the chief economic advisor,
he came on your show
and he basically said
Justin Trudeau stabbed
Donald Trump in the back.
And the worst part about it was
that he weakened Donald Trump
before his summit
with Kim Jong-un.
What is it like to watch that
take form in real time
on your show?
-Well, it's just fascinating
because, obviously,
we all saw the G7 blow up
the way it did.
And President Trump on Air Force
One firing off his tweets,
removing the United States
from a -- from a communiqué.
-Yeah.
-As one does.
-And there really hadn't been
any explanation
about why it was.
And so Larry Kudlow
came on the show.
And I didn't know
what they were gonna say.
I legitimate --
Usually, you have an idea
of what they're going to say.
But this was
the birth of the spin.
And, obviously,
it was coordinated
because they were saying it at
the same time on other channels
with different guests.
But the birth of the spin, that
this was Justin Trudeau's fault.
-Yeah.
-And it so offended
Donald Trump.
-And then, do you --
in those times,
because you're processing in
real time,
do you find, like, it's your job
to give them room
to lay this out
for everyone to see?
-Well, I mean, part of the job
is these are your leaders.
-Sure.
-What are they saying?
And then my job is to push back
and challenge it.
For instance -- I don't know
if you guys knew.
But on occasion, President Trump
has been known --
-Yeah.
-On occasion
to insult people too.
-Oh, my God.
[ Laughter ]
Breaking news.
-You really have to follow
the news closely.
-'Cause he does it
between the lines.
It's very subtle.
-It's subtle. It's subtle.
The occasional bon mot.
-Yeah, exactly.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Obviously there has been
a lot talking --
We just showed a clip.
He doesn't feel like preparation
is that important
for this meeting.
-No. It's instinct.
-Do you feel like his national
security advisers
are panicked by this?
Or do you think, at this point,
they would be shocked
if he said, "Let's bone up
on North Korea"?
-I think that
they would be shocked.
I mean, he's not -- he's never
been a detail guy.
-Yeah.
-I think that
the national security team there
is smart and prepared.
I do wonder about
this initial meeting
that they're going to have
where it's just Kim Jong-un
and President Trump
and two translators
and that's it.
-Yeah.
-'Cause usually it's not done
that way.
And no one really knows
what's going to happen.
And afterwards, no one will
really know what happened.
-Right.
Because no one from that room
can be, like, trusted, right?
I mean...
[ Laughter ]
-In the terms of a novel,
where you --
we have four
unreliable narrators.
-We do have four un--
[ Laughter ]
Now, Donald Trump doesn't --
you know, it seems like in times
that he's talked about
our nuclear arsenal
and our plan,
he doesn't seem to understand
the finer details of it.
-No, that's right.
There was a debate in 2015
when Hugh Hewitt,
the conservative
talk-radio host,
asked him about
the nuclear triad.
And the nuclear triad is --
you know, it's having nukes from
land, from sea, and from air.
And it was pretty clear
he had no idea
what the nuclear triad is.
What's amazing about
this stuff --
now, obviously,
he's in charge of it.
-Right.
-Is the idea that there is no,
"Oh, I didn't know that.
I need to bone up on it."
-Yeah.
There's no shame in not knowing
things and boning up.
-No. No. A million things.
And it always happens during
any presidential race.
All candidates get caught not
knowing things.
-Right.
-But for instance,
he has this thing.
He just did it the other day.
You know, NATO,
this -- this alliance we're in.
The deal was, the commitment
was, every country in NATO
has agreed to spend 2% of
their GDP on defense spending.
Kind of a wonky thing,
but that's an important thing.
President Trump portrays it
as, you know,
they're not paying their dues.
None of these other countries
are paying their dues.
Now, he has an argument to make
about these other countries
need to carry their weight more.
But it's not dues.
It's not a country club.
[ Laughter ]
It's not, you know,
$200,000 are owed
and then you get
the greens fees.
-Yeah, exactly.
[ Laughter ]
"They're not signing
for their club sandwiches."
-But I don't understand.
-Yeah.
-I don't know --
Have people tried to explain?
I assume people
have tried to explain.
-Well, then, the other question
is, we don't, you know, every --
We, obviously, have a sense of
what he knows about
our nuclear arsenal.
Is no one really --
Is Kim Jong-un an expert
on nuclear arsenal,
or is he gonna be too --
is he very similar to Trump?
Is it gonna be two guys sitting
in a room talking about --
-We know so little about him.
-Yeah.
-Honestly, it's so opaque
that North Korea --
there's so little that the --
that U.S. intelligence knows
about what he knows, et cetera.
As you noted, he won't even let
people study his stool.
-Yeah, exactly.
[ Laughter ]
That's how --
-I mean, that's --
So, if we don't even know that,
how do you think -- I mean.
-Exactly.
There must be a real story
in that stool for you
to bring your own toilet.
[ Laughter ]
-So they still have corn.
-Yeah, exactly.
[ Laughter ]
That's good to know.
-I'm just thinking as an --
-Yeah. Thinking out loud.
-As an intelligence officer
might.